I am absolutely convinced that 1 new cabinet
cannot be formed in the Netherlands
if aid for Ukraine falls through
on the scale on which it is now taking place
and I think
Geert Wilders realizes this
he accepts that very well
because he has the wrong one here
view and the other party to the good view
in our interest namely our value
our safety
but also the safety of the whole
alliance and of america
must Russia lose this battle
and we cannot give in to Geert Wilders here
good so you say the dutch cabinet
in any form
will do that
let's go to the other side of De Plas
watch because
in the case of Trump,
that is of course 1 completely different one
if he were re-elected
it's a good thing
you hear that you get along so well with Trump
look what i do too
here tonight HAVE said at 1 dinner
and tomorrow will repeat in 1 panel
is that I uh actually summon the people
let's stop talking about Trump
to grumble and whine
or you become an American citizen
then you can vote there
or you are not
and just have to do
immediately with the results american
predictions
of elections
I don't know what that outcome will be
we will wait and see
and the last thing we have to do is
because maybe he will come back
then further increase our defense spending
as if we were there
Need Trump for it
we are doing that
Germany is doing that
Denmark is doing that
many other countries are doing why
because our safety is in play
so stop whining about Trump
and increase your defense spending
produce more ammo
live more and Ukraine also financially
because of it
is vital to us
safety and our way of life
we will see
who the next secretary
general and whoever that is
who will uh
eventually have to work with the american president
and I SAY 1 thing
this is also in the interest of america
I have spoken to congressmen today
it is of great importance
that one realizes there that relationship
there is no NATO
not to repeat mistakes after the first world war
after the second world war
but because there is 1 directly
security interest of the United States in the game
imagine
that our part of Europe is under the influence of Russia
that becomes 1 bar
very platform from Russia to America
so it is 1 their importance
that there is 1 strong NATO
whoever is president
I am convinced that always 1 big one
majority in the congress field will support